this I I can't I can't leave before
playing this sweet little Lisa sent this
to me yesterday she goes mag
you you gotta see this I said oh I don't
know I actually already I finished
writing my show the points I want to
talk about tomorrow you know we all have
to talk about that dumb balloon she goes
now Matt you gotta you gotta see this
this is a
new Disney show it's actually a a reboot
of an old Disney show which I had never
heard of but it's called The Proud
Family
this is the show this country was built
on slavery which means slaves built this
country till this land from sea to Sea
to Sea first there was rice tobacco
sugarcane
built this country
country and we the descendants of slaves
in America have earned reparations for
their suffering and continue to earn
reparations every moment we spend
submerged in the systemic Prejudice
racism and white supremacy that America
was founded with and still has not a
tone for slaves built this country not
only filled hands but Carpenters Masons
blacksmiths musicians
and we demand our 40 acres and a mule
you can keep the mule keep the 40.
so at first as I'm watching it I was
waiting for the punch line because it's
so over the top it's this stupid slam
poetry it's making a historical Point
that's just not true obviously slaves
contributed to the building of the
country
but to say that slaves built the country
one is to really overstate the
prevalence of slavery in the United
States compared to everywhere else in
the world compared to everywhere else in
the world especially outside the West
slavery existed in this country for a
very very short period of time and
people were always uncomfortable with it
and it was being phased out from the
from the nation post revolutions
earliest days
but two it also ignores the significance
of ideas in human nature
in an end in human progress and in
history
because the slaves did a lot of physical
work
not denying that slaves did a lot of
physical labor
but the slaves very rarely did or had
the opportunity to contribute
the ideas that craft the country slaves
didn't write the Constitution slaves
didn't write The Federalist Papers
slaves didn't establish the House of
Burgesses State slaves didn't do any of
those things I'm not saying it's the
slave's fault the slaves were slaves so
they didn't have much of an opportunity
to do it but obviously uh history is
propelled in part by physical actions
and labor
and just kind of regular till the fields
kind of Labor then by physical actions
that are inspired by ideas and then by
ideas themselves I mean right the pen is
mightier than the sword
in many ways so the historical idea
Preposterous and then the slam poetry
angle so absurd
such a such a caricature but then I said
okay well you know what it's going to be
it's going to be at the end of the video
they're going to get done with this
stupid performance and then the audience
is going to be silent like what huh this
is a talent show guys why are you
then what happens no there's a standing
ovation there's no what's the punchline
the punch line is listen to our our
frankly maoist political uh screed and
then you better stand up and applaud too
kids that's what Disney's putting out
that's why DW kids exist that's why
we're doing it that's why Jeremy is
investing a hundred million dollars in
DW kids is and and the other
entertainment content so that
your kids don't I can't I'm I cannot
subscribe to Disney if that is the kind
of crap that my kids are going to see
and then I like I said what is this
cartoon it's called The Proud Family and
I thought of course it is because all
this stuff always comes back to some
deadly sin and almost always Pride so
it's Pride parades it's the it's Sam
Smith giving us Satan performance at the
Grammys we don't have time to get to
that today we'll get to it tomorrow it's
it's the proud family it always comes
back to some sin
it always comes back to some devilish
imagery and that's so anyway that's what
you're getting from Disney if you want
your kids to live miserable lives
cultivate The Vices and probably worship
Satan
subscribe to Disney that's a good idea
if you don't want that
if you don't want them to learn bogus
historical anti-historical nonsense
and you want them to flourish and be
educated live good virtuous lives head
on over to DW kids great news Mark Houck
was just found not guilty who is Mark
Howe you might remember him we've
mentioned him on the show here before
he's a pro-life activist and he was
brought up on face act charges
face Act is a terrible law that says
that people have the right to go to
abortion Mills to kill their babies
without having to to deal with
protesters or very often the pro-lifers
outside of abortion factories are are
not even yelling or protesting it's
nothing like BLM or antifa they're
usually standing there praying but the
face act has been weaponized by the
Biden Administration to try to stop the
pro-lifers even from praying you saw
this in the UK there was video we
covered on this show of a woman silently
praying silently in her own mind praying
across the street from an abortion
Center and she was arrested for it and
we are not that far off from that degree
of tyranny in this country all to to
preserve what Democrats consider to be
the sacred Act of murdering babies so
this guy Mark Houck was brought up on
these charges and uh specifically it was
because he pushed a Planned Parenthood
escort who was threatening his own son
his little son who was there also
praying outside of a Planned Parenthood
so he was found not guilty of course he
should have been found not guilty it was
a terrible miscarriage of justice that
the guy was even brought up on these
charges and while I want to celebrate
and I don't want to bring everybody down
because this is a victory we should
celebrate it
the doj still got what it wanted here
the Biden Administration still got what
it wanted the pro-abortion Fanatics
still got what they wanted
they didn't get everything that they
wanted because this guy's not in an
orange jumpsuit but they got a lot
because
they dragged him through this terrible
legal process they smeared his name and
his reputation
and they sent a warning to other
pro-life activists and don't show up
don't show up outside these clinics it's
going to be a problem for you yeah
you're gonna maybe you won't go to jail
but we're gonna we're gonna make your
life a living hell for months maybe
years
yeah maybe you're going to want to think
twice before you go pray the rosary
outside of Planned Parenthood yeah
and people are going to get that message
the pro-lifers are are so
clear-minded on this issue that I don't
it's very hard to discourage pro-lifers
but there will be some people who will
be discouraged well
just gosh I got a lot on my plate this
coming year do I really have time to go
through a potential long legal battle
I don't know that's the message that's
the message that they want they don't
they didn't need any real law they
didn't need any justice to do it they
could just wield the federal agencies
like the Jack booted thugs that they are
the same people that are kicking down
doors at Mar-A-Lago
invading the home of a former president
those same people being weaponized by a
very corrupt president it's music Monday
we got some great music today the rest
of the show continues now if you're not
a member become a member dailywire.com
Knowles use code Knowles at checkout get
two months free on all annual plans
[Music]